[موسيقى]
تعد اخر معقل وطاته اقدام الانسان قبل ان
يتوسع المحيط الاطلسي تقع على بعد 25
كيلومترا من ساحل اقليم فينيستاغ بالشمال
الفرنسي
جزيره واهره يابسه لكنها تظل اكثر من
رائعه سابقا كانت مهبطه البحاره العظام
واضحك اليوم فضاء مخصصا لقاربي صيد على
الاكثر هذا القارب واحد منهم قارب صيد
محترف في الجزيره تقوده اومدين ابنه صياد
وحفيده صياد كذلك ظلت تحافظ بكل شغف على
تقاليد الاسره من الزواج
توجد طيارات قويه تحت المياه هنا نحن
محظوظين جدا لان هذه التيارات هي التي
تجلب لنا الحياه وهي اساس سلسلتنا
الغذائيه اضافه الى عمليه الصيد تستمتع
بالمناظر الخلابه للجزيره متعه تفضل ان
تشاركها مع الكل على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
مباشر من اجل الذين
لم تسال للقدوم الى
انها متعه ان اشارك كل هذا مع جميع
اصدقائي على موقع فيسبوك
طبيعتها العذراء وبعد سكانها عن العالم
اهم ما يميز جزيره تويسون نقترب الان من
متجر اوندين في قلب الجزيره حيث تستقبل
بشكل خاص جميع من تعود على اسماكها
الاجواء لطيفه للغايه ثم ان عددنا ليس
كثيرا في فصل الشتاء يبلغ عدد السكان
حوالي 400 شخص في شهرين
من بينهم
يلقب هنا بالقرصان الفرنسي هذا الصياد
وبائع السمك لم يتخلى عن جزيرته ابدا
جولته الصباحيه تبدا من المتجر من دون شك
انا متقاعد منذ 32 عاما اجل
اعطيتها ابجديات الصيد حين كانت صغيره
يقال ان الانعزال عن العالم هنا يتطلب
عزيمه قويه ونفسيه خاصه نوعا ما
الى انفسك هل تعرفين هذا يعني ذلك جيدا
طبيب الجزيره الوحيد استقر بها قادما من
خارجها بعد ان قرر خوض مغامره استخلاف
الطبيب السابق قبل خمس سنوات لما كنا نعود
يوما ممارسه مهنتي بشكل ناروتيني يومي كنت
وارغب دائما في الابتعاد قليلا من اجل
ممارسه الطب ومن اجل الاقتراب من الحالات
المستعجله بمجرد ان وطئت قدمي جزيره ويصون
لم اتخيل نفسي ان اعمل خارجها ابدا لذلك
تحينت فرصه الاستقرار بها مهما كانت
البدايه صعبه لكنني قررت خوض هذه المغامره
لا يتوقف جومبابتيست عن استقبال المرضى
لابد ان يكون متوفرا على مدار الساعه وهو
بالنسبه لاهل الجزيره اكثر من طبيب في
الماضي كان الطبيب يقوم بكل شيء
بيطريا وطبيب توليد ويسعفنا في كل ما
نحتاجه ببساطه انه رجل الخارق للجزيره
بالنسبه لرجل الجزيره الخارق تبدو الساعات
طويله كل ظهيره يخرج الطبيب جونبابتيس
لزياره كان عليه في البدايه ان يتاقلم
جيدا مع عادات اهل الجزيره الشوارع ليست
لديها اسماء ثم ان سكان الجزيره يعرفون
بعضهم البعض لذلك لا يضعون اسمائهم على
صناديقهم البريديه في ويسون لا يلعب
الطبيب فقط دور الملكي الحارس بل ان
الجزيره التي كانت شهده على العديد من
حوادث غرق السفن تحتوي على خمس منارات
اثنان منها على اليابسه وثلاث منارات وسط
المياه يلقبونها هنا بابطال
توجه نحو التياري هنا
هل نتقدم اكثر نعم شكرا مصور فوتوغرافي
يستغل فرصه هدوء البحر كي يلتقط شيئا من
انعكاس صوره المناره على المياه لحظات
نادره هل وجدت الانعكاس نعم وجدت الانعكاس
الذي ابحث عنه كان علي اضاءه بعض الامثله
لكن لا باس هناك بعض الصور الجميله
كان البحر هادئا اليوم لكن الحاله لم يكن
كذلك دائما في الجزيره امواج متلاطمه يصل
ارتفاعها احيانا الى 30 مترا وقع دومينيك
في حب هذه الجزيره بعد ان سحرته عواصف
الشتاء التي لطالما وضعت هذه المنارات على
المحك
قال لي بعض حراس المنارات انهم يستمعون
الى صوت الامواج قبل ان تضرب المناره
فيتردد صداها بشكل قوي في الداخل تحدث
ضجيجا كبيرا فيتحرك احيانا جميع الاثاث
الموجود بداخل الملعب
مثل المصور دومينيكين الصياده اوندين حبا
كبيرا لمنارات الجزيره او
يعتبرها ابطالا بالنسبه لنا بمثابه كائن
حي قائم بذاته مره في الاسبوع تروي اومدين
للسياح قصه هذه المنارات تعود اقدمها الى
300 سنه اما الصغرى فيبلغ عمرها 100 سنه
منارات لطالما انارت السبيل امام البحاره
في عرض هذا المحيط الذي لا يرحم احيانا
حين كان البحاره يبصرون وسهم من بعيد
يدركون اقترابهم من اليابسه فهي تسير في
دمها رؤيتها من بعيد تمكنهم من الاقتراب
منها سريعا بفضل الطيارات البحريه
وقفت هذه المنارات شامخه عبر الزمن تحرس
مثل الابطال جزيره ويسون وتمدها بالصمود
في وجه قساوه الاطلسي ونزوات الشتاء
العابره
[موسيقى]